merci beaucoup pour votre présentation
alors j'ai une question juste une
question mais je vais quand même vous
dire que en ce moment en Guyane et un
sujet important c'est ce sont les
dysfonctionnements dans les familles
d'accueil on en parle beaucoup
d'ailleurs pour ne pas citer Mediapart à
fait une enquête auprès de auprès de
jeunes qui sont placés dans les familles
d'accueil sur le littoral donc des
jeunes puisque on revient d'ailleurs on
sort de la commission continuité
territoriale et la difficulté elle est
là donc il y a pas de route il y a pas
de de Monsieur Marie connaît très bien
le territoire et donc ces jeunes
puisqu'il y a pas de collège il y a pas
de lycée dans les communes sont obligés
donc d'être placé dans des familles
d'accueil sur le littoral et ça rejoint
également un autre sujet qui est
important aussi puisqu'il s'agit de
suicide des jeunes Amérindiens parce
qu'en fait ils ont été positionnés dans
des familles d'accueil sur le littoral
ils ont subi entre guillemets oui des
violences
sexuelles etc et donc quand il
reviennent chez eux ben ils n'ont rien
appris en fait ils n'ont pas évolué et
en fait il se il se posent des questions
en tout cas sur sur
leur vie et donc ma question puisque
j'ai eu l'occasion effectivement lundi
soir de discuter avec la ministre des
dégâts à l'enfance madame Charlotte
poubelle avec qui on a beaucoup discuté
et elle essaie de trouver des solutions
en tout cas des propositions pour mettre
fin à ces dysfonctionnements et donc ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Villac
donc votre instance au Conseil de la
famille de l'enfance et de l'âge est-ce
que vous vous avez prévu ou est-ce que
vous avez déjà mené une enquête sur
justement l'accueil de ces adolescents
dans les familles d'accueil voilà le
dysfonctionnement des familles d'accueil
je suis pas sûr que le suicide des
jeunes Amérindiens qui est vraiment une
problématique très ancienne ne
s'explique que par cela même si
probablement
probablement ça n'aide pas
on n'a pas fait d'enquête sur les
familles d'accueil en elle-même pour ces
familles qui accueillent effectivement
tous ces jeunes qui ne bénéficient pas
d'un collège ou d'un lycée près de chez
eux et qui donc vont vers la presqu'île
de Cayenne ou Saint-Laurent du Maroni
pour pouvoir bénéficier d'un collège ou
d'un lycée par contre on a on a on s'est
entretenu avec les responsables de l'azo
donc de l'aide sociale à l'enfance la
Guyane est un territoire où il y a
beaucoup de placements d'enfants et que
et les familles ne sont pas formées les
familles ne sont pas suivies donc il n'y
a aucun suivi des familles d'accueil il
n'y a aucune formation quand vous
accueillez un enfant de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
issus de l'aide sociale à l'enfance vous
accueillez un enfant qui a des problèmes
un enfant qui a des troubles du
comportement un enfant qui a un manque
d'affection et vous n'êtes absolument
pas formés pour accueillir ces enfants
vous n'êtes pas suivi
et vous n'êtes pas accompagné pendant le
temps de l'accueil